I used to say you again see you mr.
being here I like it when you guys
aren't doing something you know what I
mean we're here nothing Bad's gonna
happen to me wait yeah exactly
the chair is vibrating I noticed that
Ellen had a tattoo of kristen wiig-y a
sin she was a big fan yeah I don't mean
to show anyone up yeah Kona won one day
but I'm a huge fan of Jaden Smith and if
I may yes please
that's Will Smith's son right there that
is Will Smith says Jade can we see that
there
he's playing peek-a-boo get a good shot
of that there there we go yeah I did not
ask his permission yeah so he doesn't
know Jaden Smith and the family general
he knows they actually bumped into him
at Comic Con they got to show it to him
for real and and he showed it to Jaden
and he flipped out right or his mind
well now for the right reasons I I just
I was excited and I didn't think twice
and I was like oh my god Jane I have to
show you something
[ __ ] bad and it's security cause that
usually goes well is what we're hoping
we're hoping we're hoping one day Sal
gets arrested and has to go to prison
with
[Laughter]
you